we'd be looking at the discriminant and
all the kinds of things that it tells us
about a quadratic right so this is why
it has the name discriminant because it
discriminates between these different
varieties of quadratics and it tells you
a lot of useful information so it's
exactly right
mathematicians so let's just remember
right depending on whether the discrete
is positive 0 or negative what could we
say about the roots of the quadratic
positive discriminate and real there's
my symbol for real by the way sorry as
she correct not my symbol for real that
is the they the recognized conventional
symbol for real numbers if the
descriptor is equal to 0 what we're
getting a double root right or or the
equal roots which are really just two
ways or sentences and then down here
let's just constant concentrate on the
up the real probably won't worry about
the unreal a bit a little bit because
that's what feeds into what we're about
to say with regard to real roots what
can you say
if the descriptions negative you don't
have any right so no roots
okay this last guy down here it's just
what we go to very very briefly focus on
okay so there are two ways that a
quadratic function can have no real
roots right so here so for instance I
gave you y equals x squared plus 1 right
that looks like this
okay so y equals x squared plus 1 you
can just quickly compute that B in this
case is 0 right so B squared minus 4ac
the discriminant is negative 4 in this
case
so it's this situation you know every
word ok that's fine but there's another
way you could do this right you can have
a guy down here what might be a possible
equation for such a parabola yeah minus
x squared
perfect okay you can see
suzay this quadratic this new one has an
identical discriminant so this guy do
you see why right here's a and this C B
is still zero okay both a and C odd
negative one right but the discriminant
is b squared minus 4ac you see that
so because the antia multiplying right
the true negatives cancel out you still
have the same negative all you had
before okay so being that there are
these two ways to have a just going to
be 0 their real roots we distinguish
between them right we can say in the
first case where everything is above the
axis any value you put into this
equations no matter what you put in
you'll definitely get positive right a
positive value out there at the end okay
since you definitely get positive we
call these you can see from my top
heading you call these positive definite
quadratics this quadratic e this
parabola is positive definite right no
matter what value of x you get it you'll
get out any definite positive value for
y anyway now because this one is concave
up that is y is positive definite right
what part of this quadratic expression
in here makes it concave up is it the a
or the B on the scene it's the a isn't
it right because that's why this minus
one down kion's negative one that's the
part that turns it upside down so in
order to get positive definite you want
the discriminant to be negative no roots
and then you want the leading
coefficient that's what a is it's the
coefficient attached to the x squared
the biggest Sun power of X you're the
leading coefficient to be positive that
makes a concave up this kind of
necessitates or or implies this case now
key right what would you call it if it's
not positive definite definite because
whatever value of X
you put in there you'll get something
which is definitely negative negative
definite and of course it's the opposite
you want the leading coefficient to be
negative no problems okay we don't need
to worry about an AE equals zero case in
here because if a equals zero what
happens yeah you don't get a I'm talking
about this right if a is zero then you
lose your x squared term so you don't
have a quadratic in even you can lose
your B and your C you can lose those
terms you still get a quadratic but
without this guy you just get the
straight line okay so that's why I don't
have an A equals zero case these are the
two kinds of definite quadratic because
you definitely get on one side or the
other that implies if these are definite
if this is what gives you a definite
then these two up here are the officer
of death they are indefinite we don't
really talk about these all that much
because it's not that useful to know
whether something is indefinite or not
it means that sometimes you get
negatives sometimes you get positives or
sometimes you get 0 right that's neither
positive nor negative okay so it tends
to be useful when you have something
which is always positive or always
negative this would become really
important to us in the next couple of
topics we'll look at Maxim's and
minimums and when you know something is
always positive freedoms always negative
that's a useful thing you can argue from